um we have we have two two
two
like um great talks in this session then
then a break which here is like a tea
time
um if you don't know what that is
compared to to like um be amazed
um
um
um before we start uh we're on talks
we're gonna have a panel this afternoon
after tea time
um and like them don't forget if you
have any questions if you want our
panelists to to address email them here
I don't want to like you know spell it
out because it's hard to spell it's a
lot of letters I'm sorry where are you
um anyways anyways email them there
um and they will be a part of our oh
we're like I'm conversation
um but now
um I am absolutely thrilled to introduce
when wrong Zing
um who is a like um Harvard postdoc
supervised for like a solial working
awesome privacy stuff that she
apparently submitted today like 20
minutes ago so it's so it's very fresh
yes exactly
um and I will shamelessly plug she's
also also like I'm going to be on the
job market this year and so if you like
this talk then you should hire her but
of course been wrong
nope
no
pressure
um so that's um so before we can hand
over the stage if you have any questions
during the talk raise your hand and I'll
bring you the mic so the zoom folks can
I'm here and for Zoom folks type them in
the chat if you have any questions
during the talk and then again at the
end for the Q a so welcome went wrong
so for the introduction uh I'm Warren
John I'm currently a postdoc in Harvard
and today I'm going to talk about my
first recent paper on concurrent
composition serums for deep actual
privacy and this is drawing work with my
postal advisors
so to get started I want to do a quick
recap on the basic concepts the
differential privacy and the composition
so differential privacy ensures that one
person's data won't change the
distribution of an algorithm's output
too much
and in this way it can it can make sure
that the information leakage for one
person's data is going to be bounded by
a small amount of of information leakage
and this small information leakage is
Quantified by the Privacy parameter
Epsilon
and for the composition and this is a
very basic property about differential
privacy which is very nice it says
suppose we have K mechanisms and each
mechanism is absolute differentially
private and then uh suppose we are
running them sequentially and then the
overall privacy laws for the whole
system is going to be K times Epsilon
and which means the Epsilon just add up
and there's this this is a very nice
property about differential privacy
because it allows us to design a complex
DP mechanism by combining several
building blocks
and here we are making a very important
assumption is where we have to run each
mechanism sequentially
but in practice and suppose each
mechanism involves several rounds of
interactions and we may want to random
uh run the key mechanisms concurrently
at the same time
as an example uh when
um when I use my mobile phone and use
for example when I use search energy or
rather email in Gmail and make
interaction with Google which is
possibly an adversary
and suppose I use a awesome DP mechanism
to answer Google's query
and then at the same time I may also
want to look on some social media
platforms like I'm going to school uh
Instagram or Facebook and I'm gonna
interacting with Facebook
um which is also possibly an adversary
and suppose I also use an apps on DP
mechanism to answer Facebook's query
and the question is what would be the
overall privacy loss in this system
foreign
because we can use composition theorems
to reason about that
but to use this uh to have this
conclusion we actually make assumption
that
um the Google and Facebook they can now
talk to each other
and in this way
um the query issued in Google and
Facebook they are independent of each
other so then the privacy laws are
independent of each other then we can
use the sequential composition theorems
um
the question is what if they can talk to
each other
and for example if the query from
Facebook can depend on the query then
received um from Google in previous
rounds and the thing uh and similarly
the query from Google Can Depend the
answer then received by Facebook
and in this way it's not clear if the if
they can run some concurrental attack to
break the Privacy guarantee because the
privacy because of the virtual strategy
may change and we are no longer talking
about the fixed versus strategy
so uh we're currently lacking a tool to
reason the total profit loss in this
concurrent composition setting
and this is a local model
and a concurrental composition
um the concurrent interactive analysis
is also common in the central model
and for example as a hardware employee I
can choose between the two Healthcare
Systems each year and suppose this year
I'm using the Blue Cross Blue Shield
and next year I may want to switch to
the hover on system
and suppose
um so they both have net data and uh
this is medical data and it's highly
sensitive and suppose an adversary can
concurrently
um query the two systems
and the two organizations they both use
an apps on DP mechanisms to answer the
adversaries query
but they don't know then the adversary
the querying another system concurrently
then the water here can obviously
interleave its query to the two systems
like the query uh sensory Hardware
system can depend on query received from
Google Cross Blue Shield so
the end of the version you can inject
some correlations between the two
systems and it's not clear on if the
overall privacy loss is still too
absolute in this in this case
so again the existing analysis assume
that the diversity have to finish a
query the first one and then move on to
the next one
uh but in many practical settings they
are doing that concurrently
so it motivates us to study the problem
of how to account the photography loss
in the concurrent composition setting
um question
is
like if there's only one company and can
you repeat the question please
so no question is can I ask that same
question again like it's something yeah
exactly and just the basic model like
can I just query the same point and yeah
and I won't get new randomized responses
or I won't get new noise I'll just be
given the same you will have no noise
every time okay yeah all right thank you
well the privacy laws we are going to
grow up okay yeah sort of like yeah I'll
like concentrate yeah concentrate
each time you will have fresh noise
um so to give the background I'll first
introduce the definition of interactive
differential privacy and interactive
mechanisms
so I assume this audience I've seen this
classical definition of differential
privacy before and this is
we see an algorithm then it's Epsilon
Delta differently private if for all
periods of neighboring
databases and for all possible outcomes
the probability over the outcome on two
neighboring databases must be closed in
this absolute Delta cosines notion
and when Delta is equal to zero and
we'll just say it is absolute DP which
is also pure DP and this Epsilon Delta
differential privilege records
approximate DP
so
um wait
So based on other notion of measuring
the closeness
um we we we have also seen several
variants of DP in literature
um for example we have concentrated DP
1080p which are based on the linear
Divergence
and we also have the fdp which is based
on the treadle function between the
tabon and the type 2 error then
distinguishing the two neighboring
databases
oops
so all those definitions only considers
non-interactive mechanisms then release
query answers in one shot
so um but often we want to do
interactive analysis like
um we want to First do some summary
statistics and then do some fine-grained
analysis or like we want to have feature
selection and then do regression
so um the interactive mechanism allows
the analysts to ask an Adaptive sequence
of queries about their data set
and to to formally Define interactive
mechanisms we are using uh the classical
definition of interactive protocol in
the crypto literature so here we view
the interacting mechanism
as a party in an interactive protocol
um and it has so each party has three
has three components
um
so the the first one is a private input
and here the proper input of the DP
mechanism is just a data set
and the adversely there's no input so
we'll just leave it as a blank
um so and they all have random coins and
the random coins capture the randomness
of producing a query or the answer will
send to each party
and they also have a function then takes
all previous histories and produce an
answer then sent to the other party
so um and in fact uh there are many
useful Primitives in differential
privacy
um has already been interactive for
example the sparse Vector technique and
also the private multiplicative weights
so to Define interactive differential
privacy we also have another definition
which is a wheel of a party in an
interactive protocol
so this is again uh the classical
definition of view in the crypto
technique uh crypto literature so so in
the DP setting
uh we only care about the view of the
diversary
so
so first it has the random Quantum
components and it doesn't have any input
uh and the the only the method has input
so we will denote a interaction with M
tick X
and there's no private input for the
diversary
and the those are the messages uh then
they received from the mechanism
so here's the definition of the view of
the adversary interacting with this
interactive mechanism
so what is with this definition now we
can Define the interactive differential
privacy
so interactive differential privacy is
defined by asking for the views of an
adversary on two neighboring databases
I'll start finding the same
apps on Delta closeness notion as we
just said before
here is a formal definition so basically
uh instead of having uh the distribution
of one shot release
uh we're going to
um model the probability of the views of
the adversary
and also I want to highlight this
additional constraint here
um now we are considering all possible
diversary strategies and before we only
talk about the effects adversary
strategy and so we have to satisfy these
apps on Delta continuous notion for all
possible adversial strategies for
interactive mechanisms
um so now we talk about competition so
as I mentioned earlier in the talk
composition is a very basic fundamental
property of differential privacy because
it allows us to use a complex DP
algorithm by several building blocks
and we have the basic completion
theorems it says if each mechanism is
[Music]
eventually private then the over privacy
loss is just going to be we add up all
the app zones so basically all the
Amazon adds up
and for advanced composition theorems we
improve on this Bond and show them the
Privacy parameter grows linearly and
here is a sublingually and here is this
is linear and here actually is a square
root of K Factor
and we also have optimal computational
theorems which gives the exact
characterization of the Privacy uh
guarantee under the K4 composition but
they show that to calculate this bond is
actually anti-hard
and we also have other variants of
differential purposes dcdp and RDP and
fdp and there are a lot for title
reasoning about composition
and all this works are considering on
non-toactive mechanisms but some of the
work there are frames in a way that the
mechanism can adaptively choose the
diversity can adaptably be choose a
mechanism so
um the Adaptive composition can be
viewed as one interactive mechanism so
like we're composing a sequence of
non-interactive mechanism and the
overall can be viewed as a one
interactive mechanism and the question
for us is
um how to do composition for multiple
interactive mechanisms
so it it can have three oh sorry two
categories the first one is sequential
combination of interactive mechanisms
and uh it's a syllable beer stance the
proof of composition theorems of
non-interactive mechanisms can be
directly extended to sequential
composition of interactive mechanisms
because we can reorder everything so
everything can be viewed as a sequence
of
non-inductive mechanisms so it can be
easily addressed
and the interesting case is a concurrent
composition
uh where we want to perform multiple
interactive analysis on the same data
concurrently
and the concurrent composition uh was
first started in Bandana 1 2021 uh for
differential privacy and before then it
was actually a study extensively in the
crypto literature and it's often more
subtle compared to the sequential
computation and for example the standard
zero knowledge proof is no longer at the
protocols standard zero knowledge
protocol is no longer zero knowledge uh
under the concurrent composition setting
so so our goal is to say uh if the
concurrent composition will make things
worse for differential privacy settings
so in the concurrent composition for
differential privacy
uh we look on this picture uh so again
the queries can be in arbitrally
interleaved uh in the in the K
mechanisms and the query sends to M2 can
depend on the answer received from all
other mechanisms
and um
the question is what is a total privacy
loss in the K uh concurrent systems
and you may Wonder
um because there's a like many rounds of
interactions and what if we can reorder
everything and use sequential
composition to address this problem
so let me let me like explain this like
for example
um first of all in many cases we cannot
reorder all the queries
um like if one is feature selection and
the other one is regression we can now
reorder the queries
and by suppose
um we can reorder the things like if the
two mechanisms are all sparse vectors
and we can reorder the uh the queries
and suppose like the adversary uh at the
the first round of uh queries two and
one and get the answer and then go to M2
and to other query and get an answer and
then go back to M1 to do another Roundup
interaction and then go back to M2 and
suppose so the words we do this
in uh go bank and forth for K times
sorry so yeah so you can do that
reordering because it's concurrent yes
yeah okay uh I can do it another one for
some
other query has some other but for like
feature selection and regression you
cannot re-order the things so what I'm
explaining here is even if we can read
other dance we'll say we have uh some
worse guarantee if we just directly use
sequential compilation
yeah so like if we go back and forth 4K
times and suppose each spot Vector uh is
just Epsilon DP
um and then we would do this for K times
then we will have 2 times K times
absolute overall privacy loss
and we have this additional factor of K
which we don't want it here because
actually we only have two spot vectors
ideally we only want to have two
absolute privacy loss
so directly using sequential composition
is not sufficient that's why we have to
have a guarantee for the concurrent
conversation
any questions on this example
because
and the only existing result on
concurrent composition is the previous
paper showed that the advanced and
optimal composition assumes extend to
the concurrental composition of
interactive pure DP mechanisms
yeah
but the approximate GP which is Epsilon
Delta DP they show that the overall
priority loss is this
and this actually is a proof privacy
like bound and this is even sub-optimal
compared to the basic composition when
the Privacy parameter just grow linearly
and this is that
so in that open question
um as if any composition if any
composition students for non-intact hit
mechanisms tanks tend to all other
variants of differential parameters
including approximate GP RDP and fdp
and the hour paper
um the answer is yes
the composition theorems for
non-interactive method jumps can be
extended to the interactive uh
concurrent setting and we don't have
additional privacy loss
and which formally says it as this
suppose then we for all interaction
mechanisms and 1 to MK such that each Mi
is absolute I Delta RDP their
composition is absolute Delta DP then
for all interactive mechanisms uh I'm
one to MK with Finance communication
such that each Mi is Epsilon I Delta IDP
the concurrent composition is also f1.dp
so basically it says that
all
um in all composition assumes for
non-interactive mechanisms for
approximate DP can be extended to the
concurrental composition of interactive
approximate DP mechanisms and we don't
incur additional privacy loss in the
concurrent composition setting which is
a very nice thing because uh in practice
in the Practical deployment of the
petrol privacy we don't have to like
ensure that every mechanism is running
sequentially and we can allow the full
interact interaction in the DP systems
and like we can allow the multiple full
interaction
um in like several systems which is a
very nice thing
then we also show that this similar Pro
uh the similar
um results hold for the fdp which is a
more General relaxation of differential
privacy
um dense but based on the hypothesis
testing interpretation
and because I uh the serum one follows
directly from Zoom 2 for the rest of the
talk I'll only focus on the results for
fdp
can you ask a quick question sure this
point about finite communication is that
critical in some technical way yeah
because we are using induction in the
proofs so we have to make sure the uh
like interaction has finite number of
rounds so that's why
um so um so some of you may not be
familiar with fdp so this is a
generalization of differential privacy
based on the hypothesis testing
interpretation and we are considering a
single task so that each noun is the
data set is X versus the data set is X
Prime
um and then we let the random variable Y
and Y Prime on the uh be the the auto
distribution of M on X and M on X Prime
and that's the 5 be that given decision
Rule and then we can write the type 1
Arrow which is
um reject the probability of rejecting H
null when H9 is actually true and we can
also write type 2 error as Dash the top
two variable is the probability of
failing to reject each now when H1 is
actually true
then uh with step one arrow and Tab 2
error we can Define the trailer function
between uh the two type of virus
so basically the trailer function
quantifies the achievable and
unachievable boundary of the two errors
uh like of the simple hypothesisting
task
and then for FTP
we are defining our DPS within algorithm
is uh Earth differentially private
before all pairs of neighboring
databases we have the trade-off uh
between the two output distributions
it's going to be greater than f
so the app DP basically allows the truth
of a full trailer uh between the type 1
and type 1 arrow and type 2 Arrow of
this simple hypothesis testing task
to be governed by this F
so it's a larger F implies a stronger
privacy guarantee
and uh so this picture is sort of
particular rule or for the best for the
for the bathroom so here we are taking
the info over all possible
uh like yeah decision rule
so this is optimal boundary between
achievable and unachievable uh errors
and like this picture illustrates the
trade-off between the two errors like
suppose this is a solid curve is at
Target F the target treadle function and
then only this curve uh that's above the
the target F satisfy ifbp guarantee and
for all other two curves uh they are
they're below the the target f for a
certain region so they are not FTP
uh a few examples for approximate DP
actually this piecewise linear Trader
function is the trader function for
approximate GP that's why approximate DP
is special case of fdp and we're gonna
just focus on the general FTP proof
and many of you may be more familiar
with GDP the gaussian DP because we
usually use this to account for the
Privacy loss for dpsgd
um so this is a parametric family of fdp
uh which we consider the trader function
between
um two gaussian families
so here's our formal results on the fdp
which basically says uh all composition
theorems of non-interactive fdp
mechanisms can be extended to the
concurrent composition of interactive
fdp mechanisms so for FTP we don't incur
any additional loss in the concurrent
population setting
so how to prove this and our proof
actually realized this nice reduction
serum from interactive mechanisms to
non-interactive maximums
so this serum physics is for all uh
given trailer function f and for any
interactive fdp mechanism M with Finance
communication and for all pairs of
neighboring data sets x and x Prime
there exists and non-interactive fdp
maximum n and a randomized uh
Interactive post-processing T section 4
for all possible anniversary strategy we
have the view of the diversary
interacting with m is identically
distributed to the view of n of the
adversary interacting with with t then
take the N of X as an input
so how to understand this room so
basically
uh we can look at this picture
so basically this room says for uh for
any interactive mechanism M it can be
decomposed into a non-interactive
mechanism n which takes the data data
set as input and then produce an answer
sent through a post-processing function
t
and this possible processing function
does not take the data set as an input
it only takes the output of the the N of
X as an input and then interacting with
the adversary just as M does
so that's what we call the interactive
post-processing function
but it does not take any database as the
input
so basically the T simulates all the
answers
um
just based on the enough X
so so basically this serum says
um any interactive mechanism can be
simulated
by non-interacting mechanisms
so we can reduce an interactive
mechanism to a non-interactive maximum
so this is
reduction theorem
and a few special cases to understand
the non-intactive mechanism
um so we show that every Epsilon Delta
DP interactive Magnum can be simulated
by the Epsilon Delta randomized response
and Christina
introduced the randomized response
earlier in the morning and which is good
um and in fact the previous paper showed
that the similar results for every now
interactive DP mechanism can be
simulated by the Epson Delta randomized
response but we extend them to the
interactive mechanism
and the challenge here is
we have to show uh the T
the T has to be Universal then satisfy
all possible diversary strategies
and which is a major challenge for the
interactive mechanism
uh and in the previous concurrent paper
concurrent composition paper they also
show that every episode interactive
mechanism can be simulated by the the
pure DP randomized response
and this reduction system has a nice
implication in the concurrent
composition
so basically
um to analyze the concurrent composition
of K interactive mechanisms
um it's equivalent to consider the
concurrent composition of the
post-processing then take the
non-texting maximums
um so the sequence of this
and because this T does not have any uh
data sentence input
which means
we need only consider the composition of
this non-interactive mechanisms
and that's what results the compo the
composition theorems for non-interactive
maximums extend to the concurrent
composition of interactive fgp mechanums
and so we don't have any additional
privacy loss in a concurrent setting and
we show that by this reduction serum
okay this is the story for the FTP
um
and this reduction theorem also has a
nice implication even without the
application to uh differential privacy
so like when we talk about the
hypothesis testing then we will talk so
normally we talk about uh the
non-interactive hypothesis testing where
we generate a sample then and send to
the hypothesis tester and the hypothesis
tester
um
is going to distinguish between whether
this sample is generated from H naught
or generally said from each H1
let's suppose now we consider an
interactive hypothesis hypothesis
testing task
uh where the task is to distinguish
between
two interactive mechanism and 0 and M1
and suppose each mechanism responds to
queries uh in randomized and stateful
manner so what is this stable stateful
manner
it says the hypothesis tester cannot
find how the mechanism would have
answered if different queries are have
been asked so it says the hypothesis
tester may never know everything about
the whole distribution about the full
distribution so it sounds like a much
harder setting a much harder task to
distinguish
but if we we view the M 0 as a m taking
X and M one as M taking X Prime then by
our reduction theorem we can actually
show that they can be simulated
perfectly by non-interacting maximum
um the n0 which is n of X and N1 is in
of X Prime
so this means even if we give n0 and 1
to a hypothesis tester in its entirety
we cannot distinguish them any better
than it would distinguish it and 0 and
M1
so this reverse pricing uh finding that
to for the intellectual hypothesis
testing task we are actually uh won't do
worse than the non-interactive
hypothesis testing task
all right so this is story for fdp uh
now we are going to talk briefly about
the RDP so there's a independent and
concurrent work
um by Lou uh 2022 and they prove that
the similar results hold for approximate
DP and this this room is same as ours
and they also show the similar result
hold for RDP for a fixed Alpha and this
is the parameter for the runadp
so as a comparison we have the same
result for approximate DP
um but we have different extensions in
our paper will show the FTP and their
paper they show the RDP for fixed Alpha
and we actually also give a simple proof
for RDP but technically their results is
uh their proof is earlier than ours so
I'll just briefly mentioned our simpler
proof here
so we proved this by characterizing the
optimal offer sorry sorry Alpha RDP
adversity strategy against an
interactive mechanism
and then
um so so this is the optimal strategy
against one interaction maximum and then
um we also characterize the optimal
diversary against the concurrent
composition of the K mechanisms
which which shows and it can be
decomposed as a optimal diversary
um
uh optimal diversary against each
mechanism
independently
and overall optimal adversity can be
viewed as a product of this uh the set
of optimal diversaries
so in this way we can view each
mechanism independently and then we can
sum up all the privacy laws
which is um which is identical to the
um to the optimal composition for the
non-attacking mechanisms so in this way
we show that we also don't incur any
additional loss in the concurrent
composition setting for RDP
so uh I'd like to stop here as a
conclusion uh we prove that all
composition theorems for non-interactive
independently private mechanisms extend
to the concurrent composition
um of interactive differently private
mechanisms for approximate DP and fdp
and we show that by the reduction serums
that every interactive fdp mechanism can
be simulated in
um by the interactive post-processing of
an interactive FTP mechanism
and we also give a simpler proof of
those concurrent composition theorem of
RDP so combining all this together we
can claim that we don't incur any
additional loss for the concurrent
composition of differential privacy
which is a very nice property for the
Practical deployment of differential
privacy which means we can allow the
full interaction in multiple systems and
we don't have to enforce them to be
sequentially composed and thank you I'm
happy to take any questions in the
comments
okay
fantastic think you went wrong so we
have uh plenty of time for some
questions
let's just start
all right
thanks for your talk I was just
wondering for like the um
post-processing a mechanism tea does it
depend on which interactive protocol
you're using uh yeah interactive
mechanism you're using or how do you
find that
um
so this tea definitely depends on M
M so your question is how to find the
interactive post-processing function uh
uh so and uh whether this T depends on M
yeah so so
um
so this interactive pulls the proton
function in practice you can find this
by uh by like uh
right you can derive a set of functions
and derive uh like which which output of
the N then take to produce an A so you
so the T have to satisfy a set of
functions and you can you can like you
can you can have this T by simulations
uh and our on our serum just sort of
show the existence of the T but in
practice it really depends on the
specific maximum M and you have to solve
them by the computer experiments
any questions
we have one
um so you so you mentioned at the
beginning
um
um at the very beginning things like you
know spark Specter as being like
examples of this kind of like adaptive
composition
um before you begin all of your results
um what are what are some
new types of mechanisms that we that we
couldn't analyze before but we can now
where we can like analyze them in a
better and Tighter way
with these results so uh so the spark
factor is one example and before the
composition guarantee is to analyze
several response vectors running
sequentially because like we can we can
finish one spark sector and then run the
other spark Vector but now if we have K
respecter like running in the same time
wait uh running on the same time
and now we can analyze the overall
privacy guarantees if they are running
like uh concurrently so even uh spark
Vector is a simple example the previous
analysis still does not allow does not
allow us to rename about the total
privacy laws for the case bus vectors
because
as I showed here we have much worse um
price loss
other questions
all right then we can think on wrong
again
okay